It has bladder cancer and he has been treated with BCG, which is a type of needle therapy for bladder cancer and has had them scraped off the tumor scraped off.
I assume before, but they keep coming back. They are not in the muscle, so they're not called deep, so they're just in the epithelial layer, the inside of the bladder, which is the lining.
Is there something to do to prevent that from coming back?
So this question was asked by a person that I haven't spoken to for a long time, but originally, I think the person's cancer that we programmed the right for was not bladder cancer.
So definitely, I would check on that if I would have a call with me so that we can make sure that we're running the right program.
So number one, we would want to run specific programming for bladder cancer and get some more details if this has been diagnosed as transitional cell carcinoma.
That's a type of common bladder cancer, we'd want to get that detail.
So from a from a rife setting program, we'd want to be running the right frequencies.
Number two, we'd want to be doing something very specific for this cancer.
So I can't really say, oh, you should take this supplement, this supplement, or this supplement without testing.
So we really should do it on a cheek swam test too.